>> Greg: YEA, THANK YOU.
YOU WILL LOVE.
THIS SO RIGHT NOW THE
MEDIA'S FACE IS PRESSED UP
AGAINST THE WINDOW OF THE
CANDY STORE AND THEY ARE
SALIVATING.
THE GLASS FOG.
HOPING AGAINST HOPE, STARING
INTO A FIELD OF DREAMS
BELIEVING IF THEY BUILD AN
IMPEACHMENT A CRIME WILL
SURELY COME.
SO LET'S STEP BACK AND SEE
THIS FOR WHAT IT IS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE MEDIA
AND THE DIMS FASHIONING THE
WORST OF THINGS OUT OF THE
BEST OF TIMES.
ALL TO AVENGE AN EMOTIONAL
LOSS.
YOU WANT SOME EXAMPLES?
WELL, AS AMERICA LEADS THE
WAY IN CLIMATE WITH CLEANER
ENERGY, THE LEFT TELLS THEIR
KIDS WE HAVE A DECADE TO
LIVE.
AS RACE RELATIONS IMPROVE
FROM THE MASS DEMONSTRATIONS
OF FIVE YEARS AGO THE MEDIA
SEES RACISM IN EVERY NOOK.
AS MEN AND WOMEN REACH
EQUALITY IN ALL FACETS, THE
MEDIA QUESTIONS WHETHER
GENDER IS JUST A FANTASY.
AS WOMEN AND MINORITIES GAIN
MORE EMPLOYMENT THAN EVER,
THE GUY RUNNING THE SHOW IS
CALLED A BIGOTED SEXIST.
A GUY CALLED TRUMP, A GUY
WHO WAKES UP EVERY MORNING
IN THAT CANDY STORE CALLED
AMERICA WONDERING WHAT WE
CAN GET OUT OF THE WORLD AND
NOT THE REVERSE.
FOR HIM IT'S NOT ABOUT
MONEY, INFLUENCE, OR SEX.
GOD KNOWS HE HAS HAD ENOUGH
OF THAT FOR FIVE LIFE TIMES.
IT'S ABOUT THE JOB AND YOU
ARE HIS BOSS.
SEE, HE IS A GUY WHO IS
STINGY WITH BOTH BLOOD AND
TREASURE.
WHICH IS WHY HE IS TRYING TO
REPLACE REAL WARS WITH TRADE
WARS.
SENDING AN ACCOUNTANT,
INSTEAD OF TANKS.
AND, YET, EVEN AS AMERICA IS
GOVERNED BY AN ORANGE
GANDHI, THE MEDIA AND DEMS
SEE HIM AS HITLER.
YOU SEE THE TREND?
AS THE WORLD GETS BETTER,
WHICH THE METRICS SHOW, THE
MEDIA PANICS.
HOW CAN THEY REPORT GOOD
TIMES IF TRUMP IS INVOLVED
IN ALL OF THEM.
SO EVERY DAY IS DOOMSDAY
SINCE 2016, WHICH IS WHY NOW
THEY ARE OUTSIDE THAT CANDY
STORE WAITING FOR THAT SWEET
IMPEACHMENT, DESPERATE FOR
THE TASTE OF REVENGE, THE
SWEETIST BON BON OF ALL.
>>
DANA, WHILE DONALD TRUMP WAS
TALKING OTHER NETWORKS WITH
CUTTING IN AND OUT TO FACT
CHECK HIM.
ISN'T THAT NICE?
WOULD THEY EVER DO THAT TO
OBAMA?
>> Dana: NO.
AND HOPEFULLY WE WOULDN'T
EITHER.
YOU WANT TO TAKE A
PRESIDENT'S SPEECH?
TAKE IT.
EVERYBODY TO EACH THEIR OWN.
EVERYONE GET YOUR COVERAGE
AND WE WILL GET OUR VIEWERS.
I DO THINK WHEN IT COMES TO
THE MEDIA, FOR EXAMPLE,
EARLIER THERE WAS A STORY
THAT BROKE AROUND 4:00, "THE
WASHINGTON POST" SAID THAT
THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE WAS
THREATENING TO QUIT BECAUSE
HE WAS NOT GOING TO BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK FREELY.
AND THE PRESS SECRETARY AT
THE WHITE HOUSE SAID -- "THE
WASHINGTON POST" GAVE
LITERALLY SIX MINUTES TO
RESPOND.
THAT'S HER WORDS.
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED.
THAT'S WHAT SHE SAID.
AND I KNOW YOU GOT SIX
MINUTES.
I HAVE GOT TO CALL THE DNI
AND CHECK WITH THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR AND CALL
THE CIA.
YOU CAN'T DO ALL OF THAT IN
SIX MINUTES.
THEY WENT TO THE STORY.
GOES OUT THERE AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU HAVE THE ACTING
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE SAY THAT'S NOT
TRUE.
I NEVER THREATENED TO QUIT.
I WAS NEVER GOING TO QUIT.
HE WILL BE ON THE HILL
TOMORROW.
I DO THINK WHEN IT COMES DO
YOU FEEL THIS THE
BREATHLESSNESS OF THE
REPORTING IS ALWAYS GOOD TO
REMIND YOURSELVES THAT
WAITING FOR MORE INFORMATION
IS ALWAYS A BETTER ANSWER.
AND I DO THINK THAT THAT IS
TRUE FOR THE DEMOCRATS AS
WELL.
I FIND IT REALLY CURIOUS
THAT NANCY PELOSI, WHO HAD
BEEN SO CAUTIOUS AND PUT --
AND KIND OF LIKE OFFPUTTING
TO HER -- THE REST OF HER
CAUCUS SAYING WE ARE NOT
GOING TO GO FOR IMPEACHMENT
RIGHT NOW.
BAD POLITICS, WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING.
THERE IS NO SMOKING GUN, WE
DON'T HAVE THE EVIDENCE AND
DO THIS BEFORE THEY GET THE
TRANSCRIPT SEEMS LIKE THEY
WENT OUT ON A LIMB AND SAWED
IT OFF.
>> Greg: SHE WAS
HESITANTLY -- SHE DIDN'T
WANT TO KICK THAT SOCCER
BALL INTO THE NET.
OH, THEY ARE SCREAMING AT
ME.
THE BASE IS SCREAMING AT ME.
KATIE, WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY
ACTUALLY UNDO AN ELECTION?
HAVE THEY THOUGHT IT THROUGH
HOW HALF OF AMERICA MIGHT
RESPOND IF THEY TRY TO
IMPEACH A PRESIDENT BASED ON
A PHONE CALL WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN?
>> Katie: MIKE PENCE WILL BE
PRESIDENT AND THAT WILL BE
MUCH, MUCH WORSE.
SO MAYBE THEY SHOULD THINK
ABOUT THIS TWICE.
IT'S AMAZING HOW THEY
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT THE
NEED TO PROTECT DEMOCRACY
AND THE VOTING AND ALL THE
STUFF BUT, YET, THEY ARE NOW
GOING DOWN THIS ROAD OF
REVERSING AN ELECTION THAT
THEY DON'T LIKE.
AND THEY HAVE DONE THIS
THROUGH A NUMBER OF STEPS.
THROUGH THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, THIS PHONE
CALL NOW.
ANY KIND OF HIGH CRIME AND
MISDEMEANOR.
ANY OF THEM CAN CITE
PROPERLY AND THE QUESTION IS
THE MEDIA EVER GOING TO
LEARN ANYTHING.
ARE THEY ACTIVISTS OR ARE
THEY REPORTERS?
JOE, EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED BREATHE LIFE INTO
THE REPORT.
NONE OF THAT HAPPENED.
AND HERE WE ARE NOW WITH THE
QUID PRO QUO WHICH WAS
REPORTED YESTERDAY MULTIPLE
TIMES IT.
DOESN'T MENTION.
AND YET THERE IS NO
CORRECTION FROM QUITE
FRANKLY ANYBODY ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY GOT THIS
WRONG.
I WONDER IF THEY SIT AROUND
IN NEWS ROOMS AND NEVER HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
THEY CAN DO THINGS BETTER
BECAUSE THERE IS A LOT.
>> Greg: JESSE, THIS IS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE
ACCELERATING MOB SAW WITH
COVINGTON AND KAVANAUGH RED
PILL ANOTHER 3 OR 4 MILLION
AMERICANS.
>> Jesse: I DON'T TRUST
MEDIA WHEN THEY: -- GOT OUT
WAY OVER SKI AND BIG NOTHING
BURGER.
AM I ALLOWED TO SAY NOTHING
BURGER?
>> Greg: NOTHING BURRITO.
>> Jesse: THAT FITS FINE.
JUAN SAID IT IS A CRIME.
WHAT IS THE CRIME?
>> Juan: AMERICAN.
>> Jesse: IS THAT --
STATUTORY CRIME, NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO.
ISN'T THAT EXACTLY WHAT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION DID.
>> Juan: EXCUSE ME, THE
UNITED STATES INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY IN THE PROCESS OF
GATHERING INFORMATION SAID
THEY HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
PEOPLE IN BRITAIN.
THAT'S NOT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Jesse: OKAY SO THE OBAMA
FBI DOJ AND CIA AREN'T THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION?
JUAN, GO BACK TO SCHOOL.
ALL RIGHT, HERE, ALSO, HOW
IS THIS THEY SAY THIS IS NOT
EVEN A CAMPAIGN VIOLATION.
THAT'S THE LEVEL OF THE
CRIME.
IT'S NOT EVEN A CAMPAIGN
VIOLATION.
BECAUSE THERE IS NOTHING, A
THING OF VALUE ATTACHED TO
IT.
THERE IS NO -- OKAY, OKAY.
HILLARY CLINTON, THE
9 MILLION SHE SENT OVERSEAS
TO GET RUSSIAN DIRT ON TRUMP
THAT THEY USED TO SPY ON
THEM?
THAT'S NOT A THING OF VALUE?
BUT THIS IS?
NOMINEE AND THIS IS HIS IS
ON THE NON-DEMOCRAT
NOMINEE'S SON GETTING LOOKED
INTO AS A THING OF VALUE?
>> Dana: APPARENTLY THE
OBAMA TEAM AT THE TIME
DURING THE PRESIDENCY WAS
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE
JUDGMENT THAT HUNTER BIDEN
WAS EXERCISING.
>> Jesse: GOOD FOR THEM.
>> Dana: BUT DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT, RIGHT?
THAT WE KNOW OF.
MAYBE THEY STAVED OFF OTHER
THINGS.
>> Jesse: HOW DO YOU THINK
THEY WOULD ALLOW HUNTER
BIDEN TO FREELANCE IN
UKRAINE WHILE HIS DAD IS
RUNNING POINT?
HOW WOULD THEY EVER ALLOW
THAT?
>> Dana: AND THE CHINA
EXAMPLE COULD BE WORSE.
AND THAT STORY WAS GOING TO
COME OUT.
BOTH OF THESE THINGS THAT
NANCY PELOSI WAS HOPING WERE
NOT GOING TO COME TO
FRUITION OR AT LEAST NOT
RIGHT AWAY IMPEACHMENT AND
THE HUNTER BIDEN AND THE
QUESTIONS INTO THE BIDEN
WHOLE EXTRAVAGANZA THE TRIP
TO CHINA ON AIR FORCE 2.
THOSE ARE TWO THINGS THAT
SHE WAS TRYING TO STAVE OFF.
NOW THEY ARE FRONT AND
CENTER.
AND ONE THING ABOUT THE
ELECTION.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
LOTS OF DEMOCRATS RUNNING
FOR OFFICE.
WE STILL HAVE 20.
BIDEN HAS BEEN ABLE TO DEFY
GRAVITY IN ALL OF THESE
POLLS FOR A LONG TIME WITH
ONE KEY ISSUE, ELECTABILITY.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Dana: NOW HIS POLLING
NUMBERS HAVE STARTED TO COME
DOWN.
ELIZABETH WARREN'S HAVE BEEN
ON THE RISE.
THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
TIME.
THERE COULD BE CHANGES.
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT TODAY
AND ONLY THING YOU WANT IS
TO BEAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
2020, AND YOUR KEY ISSUE IS
ELECTABILITY, DOES ANY OF
THIS MAKE YOU FEEL LIKE JOE
BIDEN COULD BE MORE
VULNERABLE IN 2020?
AND I THINK THE ANSWER IS
YES.
YOU WILL SEE.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK SO
AND LET ME SAY WHY I DON'T
THINK SO.
FIRST OF ALL WHAT YOU GOT
AND YOU WERE SUGGESTING
EARLIER OH, YOU KNOW, NANCY
PELOSI IS OUT ON A LIMB.
IT'S BEEN SAWED OFF.
IN FACT, MORE PEOPLE AFTER
THE RELEASE OF TODAY'S MEMO
ARE SAYING, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE ARE BEHIND IMPEACHMENT.
AND I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE THE SHIFT IN THE POLLS
AS WELL.
AND WHEN IT COMES.
>> Greg: NO YOU WON'T NOT IN
THE POLLS.
>> Juan: JOE BIDEN AND BO
BIDEN THIS IS STILL.
>> Dana: HUNTER BIDEN.
>> Juan: PETER SCHWEIZER IS
THE ONE WHO STARTED THIS
WITH HIS BOOK BACK IN 2018
AND YOU SEE A LOT OF THIS
ECHO.
>> Greg: SCOTT KING IS
CONSERVATIVE?
>> Juan: PEOPLE HAVE
SEARCHED THROUGH THIS AND --
[TALKING AT THE SAME TIME]
>> Jesse: JUAN, IF DON JR.
MADE A DEAL WITH CHINA
WOULDN'T YOU THINK THAT WAS
WRONG?
>> Juan: THINK ABOUT THIS IS
YOU SAY THIS IS THE MEDIA.
IS THE MEDIA NOT SUPPOSED TO
REPORT WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES ENGAGES.
>> Greg: THEY ARE
CONTROLLING THIS.
THEY ARE CONTROLLING THIS.
>> Juan: THEY ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE, OH THE
MEDIA'S FAULT.
>> Greg: THEY ARE NOT
REPORTING THEY ARE
CONTROLLING AND
MANIPULATING.
GUTS GUT I HAVE A GREAT
MONTAGE WE ARE GOING TO
COMPARE TWO DIFFERENT KIND
OF EXAMPLES OF THE MEDIA.
THERE WAS THIS RUSSIAN VS.
NOW I THINK THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING OR NOT?
>> CAN I CERTAINLY SAY WITH
CONFIDENCE THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
>> IT'S A CRIME.
IT'S ON THE STATUTE BOOKS.
AND CRIMES ARE TYPICALLY
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES.
>> THE BEGINNING OF THE END
OF THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
>> THIS IS ABOUT A
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF WHO
ACTUALLY IS MEDALING
ACTUALLY IS MEDAL MG
ACTUALLY IS MEDAL MEDDLING
WITH AMERICA'S NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> THIS IS WORSE THAN
WATERGATE.
>> I KEEP GETTING ASKED ARE
THERE ECHOS OF WATERGATE IN
THIS AND THERE ARE.
>> Greg: CNN DIFFERENT
PLAYBOOK DIFFERENT DAY
TALKING ABOUT TRUMP TALKING
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
>> Katie: LOOK AT THE
CREDIBILITY OF WHO IS MAKING
THESE ARGUMENTS.
THEY ARE GOING TO SAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
RIGHT ABOUT THIS AND PEOPLE
LIKE ADAM SCHIFF AND PEOPLE
IN THE MEDIA HAVE BEEN
WRONG.
THEY HAVE NEVER PRODUCED THE
EVIDENCE THAT THEY HAVE
PROMISED.
I HAVE GOT TO SAY DEMOCRATS
BETTER BE CAREFUL WHAT THEY
WISH FOR.
BECAUSE EVERY TIME THEY CALL
FOR ONE OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS PEOPLE START
LOOKING AROUND ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON AND IT ALWAYS COMES
BACK TO PROVE THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN ACCUSING PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND REPUBLICANS OF
EXACTLY WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING.
AND SO THERE ARE SERIOUS
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER,
AGAIN, JOE BIDEN WAS SELLING
INFLUENCE THROUGH HIS SON
HUNTER BIDEN AND WHETHER
THESE DEALS BEING MADE AS A
RESULT OF HIS.
>> Dana: I HAVEN'T HEARD
THAT PART.
WHERE IS THAT COMING FROM?
I DEFINITELY HEAR HUNTER
BIDEN QUESTIONABLE JUDGMENT
THING OR JOE BIDEN BENEFITED
FINANCIALLY.
>> Katie: HUNTER BIDEN
BENEFITED FINANCIALLY
BECAUSE OF HIS FATHER.
GETTING INFLUENCE.
>> Juan: IMAGINE IF, BECAUSE
YOU GUYS KEEP BRINGING UP
OBAMA.
IMAGINE IF THE OBAMA ASKED A
FOREIGN LEADER SAY HEY, CAN
MY LAWYER, RUDY GIULIANI, OR
CAN MY ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL
BARR GET INVOLVED WITH YOUR
INVESTIGATION?
WHATEVER?
>> Jesse: JUAN, JUAN.
>> Juan: HE IS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
IF HE THINKS SOMEONE HAS
COMMITTED A CRIME, HE CAN GO
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND SAY, HEY, WE NEED TO
INVESTIGATE.
YOU DON'T GO OVERSEAS AND
SAY HEY WILL YOU GET
INVOLVED.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION WAS
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION UNDER THE
AUSPICES OF THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
HE SET THAT UP.
THEY DID IT FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Juan: THEY DID IT FOR
OBAMA?
>> Jesse: COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
IT WAS RUN THROUGH THE FBI
AND DOJ FOR BARACK OBAMA IT
WAS NOT CRIMINAL.
>> Juan: IN OTHER WORDS,
OBAMA IS THE ONE THE
RUSSIANS WERE GIVING -- HAD
SOME INTERFERENCE IN THE
ELECTION TO BENEFIT DONALD
TRUMP?
THAT WAS BARACK OBAMA?
>> Jesse: THEY JUST SPIED ON
HIM AND CAMPAIGN AND
ILLEGALLY INVESTIGATED HIM.
>> Juan: THIS KIND OF
BALDERDASH.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE SAYING
INVESTIGATED FULLY AND
NOBODY EVER FOUND ANYTHING.
>> Juan: NOBODY.
>> Jesse: GOES TO THE TRUMP
TOWER HOTEL AND ORDERS A
COCKTAIL AND LIBERALS FIRE
OFF FIVE LAWSUITS AND THEY
WANT TO INVESTIGATE AND
IMPEACH OVER THE EMOLLIENTS
CLAUSE.
JOE BIDEN'S SON TAKE AS
BILLION FROM CHINA AND IT'S
NOT BEEN INVESTIGATED FULLY?
IT HASN'T.
>> Juan: JIM COMEY WHO IS A
REPUBLICAN, ROBERT MUELLER
IS A REPUBLICAN.
ALL THESE GUYS INVESTIGATE.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
>> Greg: I LOVE YOUR
REPUBLICANS, JUAN.
>> Juan: WHAT HAPPENED TODAY
WE NOW KNOW NO SAWING OFF OF
A BRANCH.
WE NOW KNOW THAT THIS
PRESIDENT TRIED TO GET A
FOREIGN POWER INVOLVED IN A
AMERICAN POLITICS.
>> Jesse: BARACK OBAMA
ADMITTED.
>> Greg: DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S
GREAT?
EVERYBODY IN AMERICA IS
GOING TO READ THE TRANSCRIPT